ciao persone mi sono svegliato si vede
dal letto che un casino da tipo adesso
ho deciso quest'oggi di fare un best of
dei momenti di getting over it ora
chiuso le scene piretti kg getting over
it nel mentre che salivo la montagna
dall'inizio alla fine degli quattro
episodi tra video vi piace ragazzi vi
lascio a questa serie natalizia
incredibile buona visione cominciamo c'è
una pentola nel nulla
[Applauso]
fantastico bene la partenza distrutto
non so quanti anni di evoluzione del
cervello dell'homo sapiens e questo
gioco che fatto dal tizio che ha fatto
propri sono morto perché no no no è
difficilissimo raga porca eva no zitto
zitto
no
[Risate]
madonna rega cioè io veramente non posso
provare istinti omicidi per un
videogioco c'erano veramente senso
buttano andiamo ma dai
cosa c'è di così dice agganciarsi a dio
sto male oddio sto male ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo
[Musica]
ti prego ti prego aiutami io però
aggiunge la sua 22 ma che può spendere
c'è il cane che mi sta guardando da
un'ora che non ci posso fare lo giusto
che impongono finisca pensiero
agganciati alla fine è difficile andare
avanti capito a fare un metro
[Musica]
come faccio ad aggrapparmi a quei cosi
maledetti porca eva trono mi si può
chiedere di registrare queste cagate la
domenica a gesù buono poi ci appoggia
poggia riuscire a poggiare il culetto
ok no
[Musica]
ve lo giuro ragazzi grazie gesù chiudo
io devo cambiare felpa caldo calcina
veramente anche perché poi quando mi
spazientiscono inizio a sudare come un
cane allora per assurdo mi sembra anche
un pochettino più semplice basta a
tirarsi su forte chrysler veramente
piano inc è incredibile perché
probabilmente era una cosa difficile da
fare sono riuscita a farla bene che
casino
ero preso presa no c'era riuscito
c'è di sbagliato in quello che faccio
vai la fai a tirarti su mai nella vita
forse sì forse sì
[Musica]
ti giuro io veramente sento o male alle
braccia io c'è veramente africa il mouse
avanti indietro sommare alle braccia io
è il gioco più straziante che abbia mai
fatto in tutta la merita ragazzi ve lo
giuro non farò ma se mai dovessi
approcciare un gioco del genere ancora
stai zitto fa mi cosa stai zitto porca
vacca sti divani ecco questo succede
quando non sai montare le cose all'ikea
ma voi avete capito più o meno sto gioco
dove che ci deve portare bottin
sarebbero e pio ma va va
madonna senza neanche preparazione un
fenomeno un fenomeno tua madre morta e
senza paura si fanno le cose
esatto di una barca incastrata nel duomo
si no poi su questo ammazzo ti ammazzo
vai sul bravo bravissimo ok ok nonni
fermi e zitti non zitti
metti il tuo culo lì il culo no bene ok
ok cesta pantera c'è un pollice in su
mettetevi piace al video al pollice devo
prendermi che ne so io dal pollice vado
su bene c'era un jump scherza fai andare
oltre per favore grazie ma c'è una
montagna ma se di scemi una montagna di
ghiaccio aiuto con eva peron tigro pare
il cappello piano piano piano piano
piano non c'è il cappello di mezzo mi dà
fastidio
orca vac è caduto giù è caduto giù il
cappello fermi qualcuno mi esplichi la
situazione per cortesia o no ok va bene
almeno sia qua collina ok armeno fa
qualcosa nella tua vita
ok e vabbè un fenomeno un fenomeno però
termoli six ok sto andando anche bene in
questo video a differenza degli altri
però non troppo bere non troppo bene
cosa devo fare che vado saltasse da tra
sponda però mamma mia mamma mia a un
giocatore è un fenomeno oggi un fenomeno
un certo non cavalcare il serpente
vuoi un po di questo no non l'avrei come
ho fatto per cava cà fermo lì a fa il
salto decente bello secco
ha forse no
non so dove vai da lì ma non importa non
lo farò a bacca e inusabile scivolare di
brutto sto coso inusabile sensi quando
sé ma col secchio alla fine ce la faccio
più propulsione col 6 falasca va a
scusate ma riesce a farti bird no non ho
dei problemi con questo secchio ho dei
problemi per cortesia
no no no no no no tirati su ok
no no no perché si deve essere una
persona stupida dai ti prego ho quindi
io posso stare in piedi qualcosa la
sinistra
devo andare presumo comunque a destra
anche se si può fare questa cosa che non
sapevo se provassi a saltare
grazie gesù cioè fammi capire questa
montagna non ha appigli e io come dovrei
mai raggiungere la cima di questa di
questo schifo spiegami e in sali bill e
non puoi salire su star o no non puoi
non può i ragazzi ci è impossibile
perché non incastri canna no dai
no è permesso
va bene ero carino ma niente niente nel
mondo è proprio possibile immaginabile
no se si agganciava le era fatta però a
volte lo si agganciava culo sto gioco di
merda voto si aggancia ogni tanto tipo
adesso no perché fa lui decide come
vuole come li gira la giornata come si
sveglia è qui ti svegli maledizione di
svegli bene thq agganciati ti prego di
non adottare un bambino sano
andrò a calcutta o qualcosa cosa è no no
no no no no
regna su supporto schifo so io
oggi su cosa devo fare questo carrello
della coop è bravo e non è ragazzi
comunque fuori da lì le botte amiamo 6
minchiate lo giuro che lo giuro sono
quasi convinto di questo cosa mai pagato
e vagato non è un pug cioè deve andare
veramente così cosa sta succedendo mai
nella vita
[Musica]
così ciao amici dove la [ __ ] basta basta
c'è veramente io questa mano l'ho
distrutta fuori direi pugni sulla
tastiera oltre che aveva distrutto due
tastiere seconda finisce il gioco sei
contento di cia e stato bello no è stata
una merda però sono contento di non
doverci mettere più mano basta giuro
solennemente che non sto registrando
stremando questo il che potrebbe
sfoderare la ricompensa per gli altri
scalatori a c'è una ricompensa
ok non stanno registrando sapremo se mi
fa vedere la ricompensa
quindi ragazzi che sarà il best of di
getting over it spero vi sia piaciuta la
serie spero vi sia piaciuto anche questo
video per dare un valore aggiunto al
video volevo dirvi che cosa si trova una
volta che finisce il gioco quando
finisce il gioco se clicchi il tasto si
la schermata che ti si apre è
semplicemente una chat con tutti quelli
che sono arrivati alla fine della
montagna cioè tu puoi allegramente
insieme agli altri insultare il creatore
del gioco infatti quando sono entrato
era pieno di insulti al creatore del
gioco ed era una roba gli auguravano la
morte una roba incredibile auguravano
una morta anche pietro spero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa se mi piace il
momento mi piace anche marie società che
mi ha dato descrizione se non so come si
sia dei e noi ci vediamo un prossimo
video beh ragazzi non il telecomando
purtroppo lasciato a milano prova beh
mattina concedetemelo bella
[Musica]